han pasado casi dos meses desde el doble
terremoto aquí en kirikán en la
provincia de hatay todavía se están
retirando los escombros los edificios
que siguen en pie están vacíos muchos
son demasiado peligrosos para regresar
tiendas de campaña esparcidas por la
ciudad los residentes se quejan de que
no tienen acceso a agua corriente ni a
baños pero cuando se enteran de que
trabajamos para una cadena de televisión
francesa cambian el tono nos va bien
somos fuertes nuestro estado nuestro
gobierno nuestra gente todo el mundo
está en buena situación a pocos metros
una larga fila en su mayoría mujeres y
niños esperan para recibir ayuda
alimentaria de una organización benéfica
musulmana
Esto es para 12 personas
alimentos que se comerán después de la
llamada a la oración al atardecer
rompiendo el ayuno del día del ramadán
por encima de la zona de campamentos se
alza uno de los pocos edificios que
permanecen intactos el hospital Público
de dortiol abrió al público en 2021
construido con 40 millones de euros de
financiación europea la constructora
turca respetó meticulosamente las normas
antisísmicas e instaló amortiguadores en
estos Pilares el objetivo es absorber el
80% del movimiento durante un terremoto
la agencia francesa de desarrollo
supervisó el proyecto que Bruselas
ofreció originalmente como parte de su
paquete de ayuda en el acuerdo sobre los
migrantes sirios
podemos ver por desgracia diría yo como
este hospital es un éxito porque hoy
funciona a su capacidad plena e incluso
con sobre capacidad en algunas salas lo
que demuestra que estaba bien diseñado
Al principio estaba destinado a atender
a una población de unos 120.000
habitantes
junto con otros hospitales pero hoy es
el único de la región que sigue
funcionando
Se esperan otros proyectos 19 solo en
esta región la agencia francesa de
desarrollo utilizará parte de los mil
millones de euros prometidos por la
comisión europea en la conferencia de
donantes de Turquía y Siria del 20 de
marzo